Володимир Гройсман подає у відставку
з посади прем'єр-міністра України.
Він очолював Кабмін три роки.
Якими здобутками і провалами запам'ятається уряд Гройсмана?
Серед своїх здобутків Гройсман називає
підвищення мінімальної заробітної плати і
пенсійну реформу. Мінімальна зарплата з 1 січня
становить більше 4000 гривень.
Це більш ніж удвічі вище, ніж було на момент,
коли Гройсман став прем’єром. Також
середній розмір пенсій в Україні порівняно з 2016-м
зріс у 1,5 рази і становить більше 2600 гривень.
Однак багатшими українці від цього не стали.
Інфляція з'їдає підвищення зарплат і пенсій,
а Україну нині називають найбіднішою країною Європи.
За час урядування Володимира Гройсмана
значно подорожчали комунальні послуги:
вода, електроенергія, газ та опалення.
Ціни на комунальні послуги виросли не лише тому,
що приведення ціни на газ у відповідність
до ринкової  було умовою надання кредитів від МФВ,
але й через відсутність реформ у секторі теплокомуненерго.
Уряд Гройсмана майже нічого не зробив для того,
щоб зупинити масову міграцію українців за кордон.
За різними оцінками, близько 10% працездатних українців
поїхали на заробітки за кордон, головним чином - до Польщі.
Головна причина еміграції - дуже низький
рівень життя в Україні. Експерти застерігають, що
зовсім скоро це може призвести до кризи дефіциту кадрів у самій Україні.
Перший етап медичної реформи
дозволив громадянам обирати сімейного лікаря
не за місцем проживанням, а власними вподобаннями.
Кожен українець має підписати декларацію з сімейним лікарем.
Станом на нині це зробили 28 мільйонів українців.
Послуги сімейного лікаря безкоштовні.
За це платить держава за принципом "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".
Другий етап передбачає запровадження
електронних рецептів та програми безкоштовної діагностики,
яку, щоправда, відтермінували через технічні проблеми.
Ремонт українських доріг прем’єр Гройсман
зараховує до своїх головних здобутків.
Прес-служба прем'єра охоче поширювала
красиві відеоролики про відбудову українських трас,
однак до ідеального порядку на українських дорогах
за 3-5 років, як це обіцяв Гройсман у 2017-му, ще дуже далеко.
За даними міністерства інфраструктури,
більше 90% доріг зношені і не відповідають сучасним вимогам.
Повільно ремонтуються і 120 тисяч місцевих доріг,
оскільки після децентралізації місцева влада
ще не встигла налагодити цей процес і провести держзакупівлі.
Завдяки передачі повноважень від центру до міст
доходи місцевих бюджетів за останні роки зросли майже на третину.
Понад 2000 сіл об’єдналися у понад 700 об’єднаних територіальних громад.
На розбудову інфраструктури цих ОТГ
держава виділила 30 мільярдів гривень субвенцій.
Ознакою успіху децентралізації в Україні
експерти вважають поліпшення у сфері
інфраструктури, ЖКГ та транспорту.
Серед головних провалів уряду Гройсмана
називають реформу поліції. Більшість поліцейських
старої системи зберегли свої посади.
Звільнили лише трохи більше 5000 осіб.
До того ж, багатьом вдалося поновитися на посаді
через суд. Стара система в апараті міністерства внутрішніх справ
прирекла на провал реформу поліції, вважають фахівці.
Проведення всіх державних закупівель
через електронну систему ProZorro -
одне з найбільших досягнень уряду Гройсмана.
За чотири роки існування системи вдалося
заощадити майже 80 мільярдів гривень державних коштів.
Мета електронного аукціону - відкритість,
прозорість та громадський контроль за видатками держави.
Утім, сам автор ProZorro Максим Нефьодов визнає:
система потребує вдосконалення.
Корупцію в держзакупівлях ще не повністю викорінено.
Попри намагання уряду полегшити ведення бізнесу
шляхом дерегуляції, підприємці значних змін
так і не відчули.
Навіть заборона проведення спецперевірок -
так званих "масок-шоу" - не поліпшили
інвестиційну привабливість країни.
Корупція, умови ведення бізнесу, рейдерські схеми,
відсутність справедливого судочинства досі відлякують інвесторів.
У 2018 році український уряд розраховував
отримати від приватизації державного майна
понад 21 мільярд гривень, але такі сподівання
не справдилися.  Попри амбітні плани на продаж
запланованих торік 26 великих
державних підприємств, досі жоден проект реалізувати не вдалося.
Цьогоріч список на продаж оновили,
але процедура все одно складна.
Жодного аукціону з продажу цих підприємств
так і не відбулося. А це на руку політикам, які досі
контролюють окремі держпідприємства.
Директор НАБУ Артем Ситник називає
державні підприємства "основним джерелом політичної корупції".